the daunting journey to the modern world
had its humble beginnings long ago
mammoth bonus to mega cities the
evolution of shelter mirrors the
evolution of humanity it all began
around the fire
so we shed our nomadic past crafted our
first homes around the hearth
centerpiece of human culture where our
world was born
but to truly become modern we had to
unite it
it was our common beliefs that drew us
together and set us on the path to
civilization the pursuit of safe havens
has spurred new innovations new frames
of mind and new societies we built a
world wondrous a world our own design
[Music]
our shelters are the children of our
imagination monuments embodying the
human spirit these are some of our most
towering achievements brick and mortar
we have conquered the earth the tropics
art
you have seized control for nature and
built our own environment radically
reshaping the face our home planet this
global civilization reveals who we truly
are a species of limitless ambition
our outward expansion has left us
nowhere to go but up the void of space
and the hazards of other worlds pose the
biggest challenge to survival we have
yet based how will our species fare in
the centuries to come against the perils
of the unknown only time will tell
[Music]